what were you doing before comedy right
before I graduated away College Finance
degree interviewed at like two
investment Banks didn't get either one
of those jobs with my cousins that was
always the funny one was bored got on
stage in August of 2009 with an open mic
in Jersey and just like shits and
giggles yeah randomly just got on stage
I could do this for about a year and a
half I was just taking a bus from my
parents place to New York City to do
open mics making no money and within
that six months Chris Rock saw me was
like Hey man you're really funny he's
like when I write for the Oscars I was
like yes three months after that I was
in LA with Chris Rock for the Oscars I
made it baby I'm right for Chris Rock
Oscars happened I thought Fame and
Fortune would come knocking I'm at The
Comedy Store Open Mic eating Dollar
Pizza hoping to get on so that's the
reality of Comedy then I got an email
from this woman named Tina saying hey
I'm working for this girl named Aquafina
do you want to help write on her show
2017 September I got a text from my boy
Che congratulations writing for SNL now
wow I thought being the first Indian to
ever write for SNL again like Fame and
Fortune would come knocking that that
didn't mean